and there you have it 20 cam newton 19
sam darnold and at 18.
carson wentz you know if we had just
seen this
a year and a half ago we'd have been
like what the hell we got the graphic
all screwed up they got the pan
you got the panther in the wrong spot
and where's your evil logo my gosh it
just shows you what what the nfl has
become as it relates to veteran
quarterbacks
everyone wants a franchise quarterback
once they decide that the guy they have
no longer fits that category even if he
ever did they're moving on and they're
going to look elsewhere carson wentz
moving on from philadelphia to
indianapolis a lot of optimism in indy
that they're going to make this work
with carson wentz and look i i can't
remember where once was last year of the
year before i suspect he was a lot
higher than he was
yes his place suffered last year we
still don't know why because
he thrived late in the 2019 season with
as you would say a bunch of crap around
him all due respect to the guys who were
like fifth string but he willed the team
to the playoffs and then last year it it
all fell apart and frank wright coach of
the colts believes he can put it all
back together and get back to the way it
was in 2017 when wentz was an mvp
candidate he was the favorite for mvp
before he tore his acl against the rams
in december well that's why like i can't
drop them you know much farther than 18.
that's where it's got to go i mean there
is like some some recent history okay of
like going damn i've seen the guy play
at a level that's better than some of
the people in front of him last year was
not good like you talked about but man
the end of 2019
he carried the team as well as we saw
any quarterback in football to get in
the playoffs and like you mentioned and
thank you for that the 2017 year yeah
and i think both of our opinions
he could have should have won the mvp so
we've seen enough information to know
carson wentz has it in him to play
quarterback at a top 10 level in the nfl
yeah last year was a disaster in a lot
of ways but just like we talked about
with sam darnold and like you kind of
just mentioned it i mean you know
there's issues with that football team
yeah he wasn't able to create some of
the same magic you know that that year
before they were able to kind of get on
that run late in the year from the
get-go last year they were reeling i
mean from the get-go and i know they
blew that lead against washington and
all that type of stuff but you know like
sam darnold injuries on the offensive
line system that you know nobody is
writing home about to go wow it's the
greatest most creative system in
football and then even last year with
the injuries of receiver it's it was a
bunch of you know i don't again don't
mean to be disrespectful
but no names to a degree playing the
wide receiver position
no run game
i mean so there we go yeah he let some
of the circumstances and him trying to
do too much affect his play and what he
did on the field and that led to him
holding the ball too long in the pocket
you know trying to jam balls into the
tightest windows you've ever seen but
when every throw is jamming into the
tightest window you've ever seen you
know that's the way life was for
philadelphia he didn't know any
different it was the year before they
were d they were jammed tight too i just
got them in there this year yeah they
didn't have the mojo so there was a lack
of support all of those type of things
he didn't play well and it snowballed
out of control so it ended up ultimately
benching him but i still think this is a
guy with a little support that has shown
us that he's got real real talent to be
dangerous
and the contrast between
carson wentz
and aaron rodgers last year as it
relates to the drafting of a potential
successor right
rogers became pissed and focused and
became the league mvp yeah wence
crumbled and jay glazer of fox reported
at one point during the season last year
that they think that
the selection of jalen hurts in round
two
messed him up sure and
maybe it did maybe
maybe he just needs to feel like he's
the guy and you know that that's not an
indictment against the player everyone
is motivated differently and
you know he he didn't expect it it
happened and it took him some time to
get over it or maybe maybe it caused him
to just decide i want out of here and he
was never able to overcome that last
year he just reacted in a different way
than rogers did to a similar affront no
no doubt i mean i i don't deny that but
you know again aaron rodgers is like at
a different point in his career in a
staple and we know a first ballot hall
of famer and you know what i would say
the greatest quarterback to ever live so
he's pretty comfortable with his like
stance as far as in the league in those
things you know carson wentz
i mean this is why to me it was the it
was a dumb draft pick for jalen hurts he
was just getting his confidence back
from hey everybody hates you and we like
nick foles he was just getting back to
like wait i think the city likes me and
the team likes me
what we drafted jalen hurts and now if i
don't play awesome right away
all those people that i finally got back
on my side that are just barely over the
fence on my side if i struggle at all
they're all going to go wow nick falls
jalen hurts get him the hell out of here
i mean that was philadelphia they messed
that up and you know what i tell people
too is sometimes you go well look at the
games last year what he did and all that
listen i understand he couldn't he
didn't play well right our expectations
of the eagles were too high too though
you know when you sit back and look at
their year from the 20 20 season look at
their schedule i mean tell me who they
lost to that they were supposed to beat
with that team who were they supposed to
beat the packers the seahawks you know i
mean they were as good as the giants the
giants were actually better yeah they
went one and one
you know they were they supposed to beat
pittsburgh and baltimore and the rams
and all those teams
i mean no they stunk and i think that's
wence's greatness from the year before
started unreal expectations for last
year's team and i think that's also what
added the pressure on him and everybody
expected that same magic and i think
this is a you know again this is a guy
that i think got top 10 talent and with
the right team around him he can show it
and i wouldn't be surprised if that
happened this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports